I I almost feel like I'm talking about
like the Loch Ness monster or Bigfoot
bytes hockey madness all right this was
something I didn't think I was ever
gonna feel the need to talk about cuz I
expected it to go away but it keeps
cycling back around and you know what
let's just get my thoughts and feelings
an assessment on the record so that I
can move on from it the Snyder cut so if
you are fortunate enough to be detached
enough from online discussion spaces to
not know what the heck that is some
background the film Justice League was
originally conceived and was directed by
Zack Snyder who directed Batman V
Superman and prior to that Man of Steel
he was originally supposed to basically
frame the entirety of what the DC film
universe was going to be now ultimately
that ended up not happening he left
after the bulk of the shooting schedule
or at least the initial planned shooting
schedule that had happened and they had
not yet done pickups and they were still
early into post-production
he basically suffered a family tragedy
his daughter passed away and he left the
production at that point now officially
that is the driving reason it's not
unreasonable to assume that there was
tension between him and the studio
anyway because the response to Batman V
Superman was not what everyone involved
had hoped that it would be that was
still a successful film don't get me
wrong but it wasn't as successful as
they thought it was going to be nor was
it as praised as they thought it was
going to be so there may have been that
sort of underlying his decision that he
needed to walk away anyways the film
ultimately would be heavily reshot and
reworked and delivered by Joss Whedon
now Joss Whedon has a very different
feel and flavor too
than Zack Snyder does so when we didn't
when the Whedon completed version of
Justice League came out there started to
be rumblings that there was some Zack
Snyder cut of the film now let's be
clear on a couple of things right off
the bat let's be clear about what the
Snyder cut is if it exists at all what
it is not is a finished alternate
version of the film
if a Snyder cut exists then it would
have been basically what's considered to
be a work print it would have been a
rough cut it would have been an
assemblage of the assembling of the
footage that was going to be used but it
would not have completed special effects
basically anywhere there will probably
be scenes missing from pickups that were
going to be expected to be done later it
would be a very unfinished film whatever
state it exists in assuming that it
exists at all now I am gonna move
forward on the presumption that it does
in some form exist exactly what it is
how finished that is or whether what it
was at the time Snyder walked away from
it was actually what he wanted the film
to be overall it's hard to say the
inclination at this point would be to
say probably because Snyder himself
keeps bringing up the idea that there is
a Snyder cut now I'm not gonna try very
hard not to spend a ton of time or
energy basically sort of delving into
the psychology of people asking for the
Snyder cut because I'll be honest I kind
of don't get it I'm not gonna say I have
no interest in it I would be very
curious to watch it as like a cultural
artifact and you know to compare it to
the released film just to get a better
understanding about what changes were
made in the way the thing evolved and
changed under you know possible studio
pressure and definitely director change
over I would be very curious to see that
but I sure don't believe that this is
some unrealized masterpiece that we have
been denied so
you know I I'm not gonna try and work
out the thought process of people who
are who really push this this thing hard
you know and keep bringing it up and
cycling it back around again
as for Snyder himself it's hard to know
exactly what the motive from his end
would be because by as at least as far
as official word goes he left the
project on more or less good terms with
Warner Brothers Warner Brothers again
this is assuming no one involved is
lying and everyone as has the same story
they all agree on this Warner Brothers
offered to delay and stall the filming
of Justice League to give Zach Snyder
grieving time for him to come back and
finish it himself but he declined that
so it does seem odd that he keeps
pushing you know his own cut of a film
that he willingly walked away from now
again the circumstances weren't once he
would have chosen for himself obviously
no parent would ever choose that but I I
wonder if there's two things that I
think might be a play for why Zack
Snyder himself keeps bringing up this
idea that there's a sniper cut the first
is is that we don't know exactly how
drastically the changes were I mean you
can watch the finished version of
Justice League you definitely feel a lot
of joss whedon in it but it's hard to
know how much of that is dialogue
rewrites and how much of that is serious
structural rejiggering of the whole
thing it feels like there's that going
on but it's hard to pinpoint all of it
so if we are in a situation where Zack
Snyder walked away basically thinking
look I've more or less finished the film
all you folks have to do is a few
pickups and to do the post-production
you can get by without me and then when
the film came out it was very heavily
reworked or maybe he did not think that
was going to happen that might be one
reason why he has an interest in the
supposed to senator kept being released
the other one if I'm gonna be really
cynical his stock as a director is not
in the best place
right now it was a while before he
started working on his next project the
next thing he's directed that's gonna be
released as a film called army of the
Dead which is a $70,000,000 zombie film
being released on Netflix now in and of
itself
none of these are inherently bad things
there's nothing wrong with a mid budget
movie I could actually use more mid
budget movies nothing wrong with
something being released on Netflix
however this can't help but feel like
the guy needs a career resuscitation
because zombies is truly going back to
the beginning his first directed film
was was Donovan was the remake of Dawn
of the Dead dropping down to 70 million
dollars well you know that's not
necessarily a budget to wipe your nose
at and that's a big drop from the kinds
of budgets he had been handling really
since I guess Watchmen
I mean Watchmen was hugely budgeted I
don't know what it costs to make sucker
punch but he definitely pulled a lot of
clout to get that made but then there
was Man of Steel there was BBS there was
Justice League these were massive budget
70 million dollars is not a lot
comparatively so it does kind of feel
like he's in director jail seems a
little harsh director community service
I suppose and that might give him a
little more motivation to push the
narrative that there is a better version
of this film that still has his name on
it out there that folks just haven't
seen so let's talk about how likely is
it that we will ever see this Snyder cut
okay here's where I have to be brutally
honest we're probably never gonna see
this thing at least it's never going to
be released in a way that is going to
make the people who are calling for its
release happy because whether they are
going to own up to this or not the
people who want this or at least or at
least the vast majority of them it seems
very clear to me what they want is they
want a do-over on Justice League
now again for whatever reason whether
they just really want to know what
Snyder had done maybe they really liked
BBS and they they didn't like what we
did who knows but what they want is to
see a completed finished film finished
special effects exactly what Snyder
would have released to theaters and we
are never going to see that for one very
simple reason there is no way in heck
Warner Brothers would ever be able to
recoup the expenses of finishing it
because post-production special effects
are dang expensive now they could
release whatever they currently have
which as I said most likely is a work
print a rough cut and they could release
it as it is with placeholders and
unfinished special effects and that will
cost them virtually nothing to do but
the thing is and I think Warner Brothers
knows this that won't satisfy the people
calling from the Snyder cut they will
simply then start shouting you gave us
an incomplete movie you didn't give the
film a chance to be seen properly the
way it was meant to be seen but again
like that would like minimum minimum for
just using Justice League as a template
for how high a percentage of the film is
going to be special effects for my money
minimum hundred million dollars to get
the Snyder cut even vaguely up to a
releasable standard in terms of what
would have been expected to hit theaters
at the time the Justice League movie
came out and whatever others is never
going to spend that because as loud as
the Snyder cut people are and as much as
to my frustration and annoyance it keeps
getting refreshed because the reason
this came up is gal gadot and Ben
Affleck both tweeted out hashtag
released the Snyder cut why did they get
on this bandwagon I have no idea but it
keeps getting refreshed but what these
people want is not
realistic and I'm not and again I'm not
even saying I wouldn't like to see that
I would said that early on it and I
stand by that but no studio is going to
shell out again
ballpark had a guess somebody uneducated
but I still feel confident in this
number about a hundred million dollars
for a niche alternate cut that you know
to just to placate a relatively small
audience especially when the franchise
as a whole is doing just fine in the
absence of the Schneider cut
Aquaman was their biggest film to date
biggest DC movie today
not even just DC EU period biggest money
maker for a DC character wonder what my
sequel comes out next year that's
probably gonna do really well
Shazam did very well there is a pretty
strong connection between the people who
liked Batman V Superman who dislike
Marvel and disliked some of the new
directions the franchise is going right
now and the people who are calling for
the Snyder cut and I'm not trying to be
dismissive here but from a strictly
numbers game thing the box office has
shown Warner Brothers does not need to
placate that audience because if this
ticked off audience who wants the Snyder
cut then getting what they want
wouldn't boost the box-office for the
things they're doing it would just it
would shut them up but like I said the
expense of doing it I don't think that
balances in anybody's ledger now is that
me saying god I hope people stop talking
about the Snyder cut well yeah kind of
but only just because I don't think
it'll I do not see a world in which it
ever happens and so when I kind of like
when I see it come up it's not because I
think the sentiment is completely
misguided it's not because I wouldn't be
interested in seeing the thing it's just
because well it's like the people who
did the crowdfunding thing to remake the
last Jedi it's like really you're gonna
sink your time into the because no
that's no well you know this stuff just
isn't gonna happen and for that reason
alone I would kind of like it to stop
having to listen to it but like I said
people keep reaping on its nightly keeps
bringing it up gal gadot now Ben Affleck
and of course the people who have wanted
it from the beginning have not stopped
asking for it so I don't know how much
longer this whole thing will go on but I
think barring any major revelations or
an actual release which would blow my
mind but barring that I think I'm done
talking about it
The Cider cut what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are Rob something
down in the comments let's talk about it
other stuff to do as well if you like
what I do you can support me on patreon
which would be something wonderfully
appreciated but even if you don't do
that there are our buttons like
subscribe share this around leave a
comment as I said all things help me out
and boost the signal of this channel but
you also don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just fronting the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]